[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We're trying to solve
one of humanity's biggest
problems, which is how will
we sustainably generate
energy in this new world where
energy usage will only go up
from here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
How do you approach
the monumental challenge of
innovating renewable energy?
During a 13-year project
that concluded in 2020,
the Makani team set out to
take on the challenge using
technology inspired
by kitesurfing.
I'm Priyanka, a developer
advocate with Google Cloud,
and I wanted to learn more
about how Google Cloud played
a part in the search for a new
kind of wind-powered energy.
How were the kites
tested and simulated
to further the
project's progress?
The team gave me
the inside scoop
on how Google Cloud powered the
simulations and data processing
for the energy kites.
I am very excited to find
out how the kite simulation
logs were collected, processed,
analyzed, and visualized
to make continuous
improvements to these kites.
But before we jump into
the technical background,
let's see a quick overview of
how wind-powered kites actually
work.
Makani's energy kite
was an aerodynamic wing
tethered to a ground station.
To begin flight,
the kite used rotors
to hover vertically in the air.
Once at full tether
length, the kite
transitioned into
crosswind flight,
flying in vertical loops.
As the kite flies,
the rotors are
spun by the wind, generating
electricity that is sent
down the tether to the grid.
The kite's path is managed
by the flight computer, which
guides the kite even
in turbulent wins
and safely returns it
to the ground station.
So those are the basics.
But to understand how the
Makani energy kite worked,
it is helpful to look at how the
mechanics of a traditional wind
turbine translated
into a crosswind kite.
The blade on a wind
turbine redirect
wind and creates one force
that pushes on the tower,
and another that pushes
the blade forward.
The forward push of the
blades turns a generator
to make power.
The crosswind kite is like
freeing a blade from the tower.
The freed blade, now a wing,
is able to grab more wind,
therefore making more power than
it could when stuck to a tower.
The crosswind kite
grabs more wind
and generates more
power for the same size
wing from the wind turbine,
but with less materials.
PAULA ECHEVERRI: Trying to
extract power from the wind.
And that's what we would get
closer to when we went testing.
It's like the actual
wind, the physical world
where our technology
had to work well.
So sometimes the challenges
were it was not windy enough,
and we were sitting
there waiting for wind.
And then sometimes
it was too windy.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Because flying a real kite
is expensive, Makani's
team created software
that would simulate the kite
flying with all the wing
components, and as
much of the physics
they could simulate
close to a real kite.
They needed to run the kite at
many different wind directions,
at different altitudes.
So they would generate hundreds
of different configurations
to simulate the flight.
Then these
configurations were fed
into Compute Engine
instances that
would run the kite simulations.
The Compute Engine instances
would be created dynamically
to run these simulations,
generating log
files and reports, which would
be then saved in Google Cloud
Storage.
And these Compute
Engine instances
would eventually
shut down themselves,
saving cost and
staying efficient.
After that, the software
engineers in the team
would pull these logs
and analyze them.
They would look for issues,
red flags, things such as "kite
did not fly very well."
There are some issues here.
They would make
new modifications,
and then restart the
simulation process again
to go through the logs again.
And this process keeps repeating
until the team felt confident
that the real kite
will not crash
under those circumstances.
Once satisfied with
the simulations,
they would go to a real testing
site, such as Hawaii or Norway,
to fly an actual kite.
And as the kite is flying,
it would send the logs
to the Command Center on ground.
Once the flight
is done, the logs
are then sent to Google
Cloud Storage for engineers
to analyze again.
They repeat the same
process, look at the data,
analyze it, make modifications
to those configurations,
and then go back
to the first stage.
Run a bunch of
simulations, verify
that those changes will
make the code fly better
and won't crash, and will
repeat the entire cycle.
Now, let's talk
about data analysis.
The engineers had two
ways to analyze the data--
Manual lookup, which
is downloading the file
to their computer, loaded into
MATLAB, or use a Python program
and run their own
analysis scripts.
But with a project
like this, there
needs to be a well-defined,
consistent analysis that
could run over and over
on all the flight data.
For that, they built a
data analytics frontend
on App Engine, where
an engineer would
submit a request for all the
logs in a particular time range
and analyze them with
these predefined criterias.
App Engine will store the
request into Cloud SQL
and send it to pub/sub
messaging service.
Jenkins master will pull
the analysis request
and distribute the job to a
bunch of Compute Engine worker
instances.
These instances
were always alive,
waiting for requests
to be sent to them.
The worker would send a
request to Cloud storage
for the log files for that
specific date and time range,
process those logs for
analysis, produce the results,
and then store them
back in Cloud SQL
and publish to App Engine.
Essentially, the Makani team
ran a bunch of simulations,
collected a ton of data,
and learned from it.
Then they flew a real
kite, studied that data,
and reiterated the process for
the next successful flight.
Google Cloud played a
critical role in this process
by providing them a scalable
infrastructure for simulations
and data analysis,
while keeping them
focused on the real problem
of harnessing wind energy.
Though the Makani team's
journey has drawn to an end,
they set up a portfolio
of open source resources,
including technical reports,
videos, documentation, patents,
code, and more.
Check out the Makani website
to get a full overview.
If you are interested
in learning more
about Makani's
journey, they also
shared a full-length
documentary,
which we have linked below.
Makani's goal was to
harness wind energy,
and Google Cloud
played a huge role
in providing the
resources needed
to do just that without worrying
about the infrastructure,
scale, and data processing.
In this behind
the scenes series,
we will continue to explore
how Google Cloud powers
incredible projects,
such as Makani.
And I'm looking forward to
taking this journey with you
all.